what's going on reject nation greg and
john here today
we are about to show you our trailer
reaction for
halloween kills now we actually tried
putting this up
last night but companies like universal
automatically copper i claim you no
fighting chance and sometimes they
really suck
balls but speaking of balls today's
video is sponsored by
manscaped you know in all honesty i'd
like to believe that michael myers
himself would use manscaped he was
locked up there for so long you know
he's got his crazy scary situation
going on down there he needs to stay
aerodynamic as he sucks through the
night
trim that bush mike and guys look i know
you've heard a bunch of people already
talk about
manscape but i'm here to tell you that
on sunday i went to
town on greg's special area i'm like
we've had these boxes for a while
i'm gonna just really use them and come
from the heart normally it comes in like
this perfect package but it's obviously
not in there because i used everything
inside this perfect manscape package i
use this lawnmower for in the shower
john can you get that for me please
oh you sick son of a [ __ ] i use that on
my balls oh
now it's on my balls this thing is
waterproof and i'm telling you being
able to use an electric razor in the
shower is very convenient
it comes with a couple of different
attachments i specifically use this one
i specifically use this one wow you
didn't even flinch i can
see what you look like and then top it
off and tell you guys truth
i use this crop reviver which is a ball
toner so my balls are really toned and
then i use this crop
preserver a ball deodorant i'm telling
you making love to my fiance i was like
who the hell are you sleeping oh
it was my balls it's like a brand new
package down there
someone might say a perfect bag yes so
guys
if you want to get yourself a perfect
manscape package you go down to the
description box hit that url link use
promo code real 20
and get yourself 20 off and of course
you get free international shipping as
well
i'm telling you as a guy as hairy as me
i am
very grateful for this and in times of
copyright claims it's nice to work with
a
company actually use their products save
your balls today
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no
no
oh
damn
get him michael my grandmother was right
the boogeyman was real it's over we
can't hurt anyone ever again
yeah right no one told you
told me what somebody in there
ouch ouch that head trauma
should not have to keep running evil
tonight
[Music]
i'm not just gonna sit and watch another
innocent person die
if you track michael's victim
silver shamrock he's getting creative my
god is getting creative
what do we do we fight let's send him
down
all ahead it feels good after yeah get
your pitchforks
the man couldn't have survived that fire
[Applause]
the more he transcends ouch so much
hedgehog
is the essence of evil
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
whoa there's a cool uh twist on the
theme there with that cello
how many people can you slam up against
a wall
classic michael move man it's one of his
favorite moves so much of that if i can
stab you into the wall even better
a trailer packs literally the biggest
punch in the world there's so many
punches and there's so many slams it's
intense
those slices looks like he's killing
like children halloween yeah
well you get them up there on on the on
the fun little park
items with the help of the the
merry-go-round
i think they upped the cinematography a
lot in this one i love the idea of
haddenfield
them sort of banning together like as a
community to take down this
one unstoppable force and they've
certainly like if this is what they're
showing you in the trailer i can only
imagine how just
insanely gory it actually is oh yeah and
the film itself like the first one was
though or the last one was pretty damn
brutal and pretty metal with its
freaking murders but this one i think
they're going to take it to just the
next
level here oh yeah well i mean just
looking at the array of
weapons they give michael from that fire
fighter scene alone he's got like
a big circular chainsaw he's got a
fireman's axe he's got like a pickaxe at
one point
like it was starting to remind me of
like other killers too i was like oh
there's a little hairy warden there's a
little bit of uh you know texas chainsaw
in there
yeah you know but all in the sort of
raged out michael myers persona
i did get vibes of both halloween twos
in here absolutely
both the original halloween two and the
zombies and the rob zombie one
uh just looked quite a bit especially in
how violent it is and the kind of
violence that's on display here
yeah it's like scuzzy and mean and and
feral
but at the same time this movie looks
really intense
suspenseful entertaining i wouldn't say
it looks scary though i was never
scared watching the trailer yeah and i
wasn't exactly scared watching the first
one i or the last one either it's really
confusing when you say first
i wasn't scared of watching the last one
but i did quite enjoy it we gave a lot
of positive praise towards the movie
what i appreciate about it was the kind
of the character-driven nature
especially of lori strode or the strode
family in total this is the first
official trailer
so i wouldn't expect them to really hone
in or capitalize on that so much
however that's something that i hope
they carry through to hear because that
was a part of what really elevated the
first movie for me was that
sort of that sarah connor nature to the
film yeah and while you got
some of that here in the hospital like
dammit check my we're gonna
we're gonna do this we're gonna end this
once and for all i wanna keep that
element there but it actually looked
like a lot of
fun yeah yeah it looks like it's finding
well
you know those the rob zombie movies do
have a certain element of brutality that
does feel like it's apparent here and
yet
those movies i would not describe is fun
and this does look like it could have a
certain thrill element and maybe split
the difference
still give you some of the thrills and
the popcorn that you want while also not
sacrificing just the menace and the evil
at the core of michael myers
and so yeah and also just having the
prospect of like the entire
town is taken to the streets i don't
know how that is going to work
in terms of michael killing them them
coming after him
but it's certainly a fascinating
prospect
so you see a murder all ahead of you
there's there's there's a third movie
already in development well it's
supposed to complete it and laurie being
like evil dies tonight i'm like uh no it
does not
unless this the halloween ends takes
place during the same night or something
like that
what makes it fun to me why i'm using
that word was
because when watching this i was like
yeah kill michael kill
that's what it brought out of me was go
out there murder let's have some fun
with the annihilation aspect and the
massacre here i don't know how tonally
it'll register
but as it stands i'm excited for it man
i like the first one quite a bit and
last one whatever i liked quite a bit
and this one uh this looks like it's
gonna deliver even more
more of a visceral impact yeah plus some
fun for you halloween three fans out
there with the masks
got a little halloween three yes yes
thank god you pointed that out
that's what the people care about is
silver shamrock
guys leave your thoughts down below are
you excited for this subscribe click
that bell hit that
like button and hey we'll catch you guys
soon and also thanks to manscape
for sponsoring this video and for making
me think my woman was cheating on me